Justin we both looked at the Final
Fantasy 15 trailer and I gotta say I'm
actually kind of excited about Final
Fantasy 15 and part of it is that it
looks really good like surprise I I
wasn't prepared for watching on out
watching in glendale it's gonna be a
whole bunch of cutscenes and they're
like there's a point where you realize
that what you're watching is gameplay
and that just kind of took me aback a
little bit but I had to rewatch it and
go so like what parts of this can I tell
or almost definitely gameplay and which
parts aren't in it I really can't tell
the difference yeah it sounds like at
the stage they've reached the point
where probably everything is inside the
in the same engine and we don't have to
really worry about what's taking place
in one place or another because it's
it's just all going to be essentially
the same storytelling gameplay together
in one sort of presentation which is
which is not necessarily new that's one
of the things I love about say metal
gear solid 4 but you know seeing it here
is seems very impressive yeah having a
game that's obviously built for the
ground up for well maybe felt for the
ground up for PlayStation 4 and Xbox own
because but didn't this start like 20
years ago about 20 years just for the
ps1 I don't think we're going back that
far but it was part one of the original
final fantasy 13 games that were were
announced along with augie toe and and
the original final fantasy 13 this was
final fantasy versus 13 but you know
it's it looks good i like the the road
trip vibe a lot of people you know kind
of looking at the a we're crossing we're
crossing the country in a in a
convertible and a kpop band vibe of like
four super handsome dudes with awesomely
coiffed hair just like bopping around in
their car belt buckles everywhere yeah
and they're all leather super slick and
smooth nothing bothers me about all this
crazy stuff happening around it it's the
combat that is what people are really
talking about from this trailer though
it's what does that mean what kind of
game is this why is it exactly and I
wish I had a good handle on exactly what
it plays like because we don't really
see anything in terms of interface
except for the party health bars and so
it's not really clear you you surmised
earlier that there might be a final
fantasy 12 sort of system where you can
program the AI to do things while you
control one character and one thing
that's probably gonna piss some people
off is this obviously is not turn-based
I mean even though we're going to the
core Final Fantasy 15 numbering the this
is obviously action-adventure combat
this is gonna be it looks very similar
to kingdom hearts I mean you see the
numbers when you hit the guys so you're
doing damage that's RPG based but it's
it seems to be happening in real time
i'm gonna guess you don't just like say
a fight and then watch your character do
it my my favorite moment in the entire
trailer is them driving by in this giant
beast or whatever behind them and they
say that's its face which is both funny
to me because it doesn't strike me as
though i don't i don't know well we'll
have to wait and see what the writing is
like in Final Fantasy 15 but it really
is a great moment where you get an idea
of just how massive some of these beasts
are and then at one point they they
actually look like they're taking a
break they're pulling over you know it
at Waterside and you see what looks like
giant brontosauruses in the background
and I'm kind of curious about this world
which it strikes it's a of the real
world right it's a fantasy version of
the real world that has cars that have
some kind of engine sound it's obviously
not electric because it has a really big
engine it's coming through the one thing
that worries me is as we as we shut this
conversation down though is so it's now
real world and just shut this off now if
you're worried about spoilers for the
final fantasy 13 series which ended with
lightning returns also turn it off now
you're also saying real world with
massive brontosauruses and a pillar of
interjecting so but it's it's not you
know for example like another place
another planet another like a completely
made-up it does seem to be like a
fantasy version of our own world and so
everyone is super handsome well of
course like you I but it's interesting
to know that lightning returns ends in
essentially the real world and so I kind
of wonder about any potential
connections that
is trying to make or whether that's
meant to be more of a just more of a
thematic transition because Final
Fantasy generally is not a connected
world each especially when you get into
the numbered ones they become very
distinct but since this was based on
that original fabuleux crystal is no
vowel yeah everything that might be a
good very no but I I'm hoping that I'm
hoping that they just split it off and
you know who knows I mean that is its
face they tell us right there that's its
face I wouldn't have known